people think that what I do is I write
novels about children no I don't I write
novels about humans but humans begin as
children and my model was I want to
write novels as if they were biographies
Ender's Game is one of the biggest
science fiction stories of all time and
when the Hugo and nebula Awards those
are two of the most prestigious sci-fi
literature Awards it spawned a giant
franchise books 19 of them soon to be 20
as well as graphic novels even a
Hollywood blockbuster to this day it's
still read and cherished by millions of
readers 35 years after its release this
week we're gonna change gears with a
different kind of guest as many of you
know I'm a huge sci-fi fan and a
bookworm so we're talking with Orson
Scott Card one of the biggest names in
the genre the Ender's Game story starts
with humanity's attempts to prevent the
next great war with foreign invaders by
having government agencies breathe child
geniuses and then train them as the
ultimate soldiers aside from the foreign
invaders being aliens this future
doesn't seem all that improbable Scott's
work is often set where he can imagine
the technology and politics of the
future these days sci-fi has been
invaded by radical left ideology writers
focusing on social justice Street credit
rather than stories about the human
condition but Scott continues to
challenge his readers and himself with a
massive body of work telling stories not
just of sci-fi of magic fantasy even
religious fiction and Shakespeare
adaptations in our conversation we
discussed why many sci-fi writers are
entering new genres what drove scott's
write an entire novel as a narrative
response to Stephen King's Pet Sematary
why the force is the worst part of Star
Wars and attacks from critics on the
themes of Ender's Game
[Music]
I'm excited to welcome Orson Scott
Card's today's Sunday special if you
want to hear the bonus material behind
the paywall you need to go over to daily
wire comm slash subscribe and become a
member there's gonna be all sorts of
good stuff over there go check it out
right now Orson Scott Card welcome to
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special oh
it's my pleasure
so why don't we start with the sci-fi
genre itself so most of the books that
you've written are in the sci-fi genre
why do you choose to write in that genre
so much oh do you want the short version
or the long version the real reason I
started writing sci-fi was that back
when I was starting to try to write to
make money to try to pay off the debts
of the theater company I had started
because I was a theater guy I thought
the only thing I could write that might
make money would be science fiction
because with you know if I tried to sell
mainstream fiction of The New Yorker or
women's fictions a red book I was gonna
run up against the top writers in those
fields but with science fiction you
can't make very much money writing short
fiction so all the short fiction writers
that get introduced through the
magazines I knew that they quickly moved
to writing novels for which they can
actually from which they can make a
living so I figured the competition's
always removing itself in the science
fiction field I'd read enough science
fiction that I thought I could write it
I was almost right I was close with the
first few things I wrote but then I
wrote one that I thought was a surefire
winner I thought of the years before and
it was a short story version of Ender's
Game and even then it still took a
couple of years before it found its way
into print but then ever since then
that's the place where my fiction has
been welcome I have written some things
that are definitely not shanwa and no
one cares because what the bookstores
want is something that they can put in
the same section with those books of
mine that have have sold and so it works
better if I work within that genre it's
not just science fiction in fact I'd say
I've probably written more fantasy than
science fiction but that's where the
field has gone most of the science
fiction writers from my early years are
writing fantasy now like George Martin
he
the best new writer of the year I think
right before me and the Campbell Award
for best new writer and so George's
obviously moved over to fantasy in a big
way and he's doing great so I also do
some fantasy but that doesn't do as well
as Game of Thrones but then nothing else
does so actually I was gonna ask how you
distinguish science fiction from fancy I
know this is sort of a rich and ongoing
debate in the sci-fi fantasy world is is
where the separation lies the the
description that I dread the made most
sense to me is that in the world of
fantasy there is sort of an element of
the mysterious that doesn't exist as
much in the world of science fiction
where everything is supposed to be
explainable for a reason but what's your
take on that that is closer that one
than the usual one which is that science
fiction is stuff that has not happened
but is possible and fantasy is stuff
that doesn't happen and isn't actually
paused a little but we can imagine and
that almost works except for the fact
that it's considered science fiction if
you do things like faster than light
travel or tundra and those can't happen
time travel especially because the
string of causality is unbreakable you
can't move back to cause that which
caused you so it's arguable either way
but I learned the practical definition
right away I had written some
science-fiction stories and I set them
off to analog and the new edge or john w
campbell had passed away during the time
that my manuscript was in the mail and
and so the new editor read a couple of
drafts the things that the stories that
now are in my book the Worthing saga and
I knew they were science fiction but
what I got back was a letter saying that
a lot publishes science fiction and
these are obviously fantasy and I
thought why why and then I remembered
looking at the bookstore the books in
the bookstore looking at the covers and
I realized here's the difference and
it's the one that actually functions in
the real world the covers of fantasy
books have trees the covers of science
fiction books have sheet metal with
rivets
and so it's rivets versus trees and if
your story is illustrated with with
rivets it's sci-fi and if it needs trees
to be effective and it's fantasy so so
when you're creating one of your books
do you start with the characters or you
start with the platter do you start with
sort of the world what usually comes to
you first
there's no usual anything can come to
you it's an exercise exercise I do with
my writing students I call it a thousand
ideas in an hour and I just sit there
and ask them questions and they come up
with random answers and the answers will
trigger something that makes you go oh
now what about that that awakens a
response in you so sometimes it's a
world sometimes I'm just doodling the
map and I start naming the countries and
then I start thinking of why would it
have that name that's weird that's dumb
and as soon as I get to that's dumb then
I know I'm probably onto something
because I've thought of something that
doesn't make sense to me and if I
thought of something that doesn't make
sense it means it came out of my
unconscious because my conscious mind is
so flaming ly rational that I don't come
up with nonsense
so the nonsense then you find a way to
explain it so it stops being nonsense
then you start finding that you're in a
world where a story can take place but
sometimes I start with the character
sometimes I start with somebody who has
a certain power sometimes I start with
just an idea like there's some recent
books I've written I started with the
idea you know I'm tired of superpowers
what about micro powers what about
powers that barely do anything but they
do that thing and and the kind of power
that you could believe somebody might
actually have somebody passing you on
the street not wearing spandex might
have a power like this the most absurd
one is that there's a person who in this
in this fictional world who knows when
someone approaches whether they have an
inny or an outy navel and this is
meaningless
absolutely minutes until she realized
that she can detect it even with people
that she didn't know were there so
nobody can sneak up on her because she
knows the bellybutton before they get
get close so there's a
having a somewhat practical use for her
but is absolutely trivial there's I have
a girl who could make people yawn yawn
uncontrollably and she uses it almost as
a mercy killing for guys who are trying
to ask her out on a date that she
intends to refuse is that she just makes
them yawn before they can get the the
proposition out and just gives up and
walks away because they can't stop
yawning and so but it ends up you know
somebody's running away from the cops
it's really hard to run fast while
you're yawning it really is you know
think about it think about what happens
to your vision when you yawn strongly
youyou kind of go blind for a minute and
so she ends up having a practical use in
a crisis things like that and those
micro powers have spawned two novels so
far I expect to do more because I have
such fun with them now it turns out that
my hero always has something that's
maybe a little bit more major than those
deliberately trivial examples but it's
just fun so I started thinking about
what what micro power would be would
make for an interesting story
so I decided with one it was a person
who finds things not really anything he
finds he knows who it originally
belonged to and he can take it back to
them he knows where they are and so it's
not that you can say I lost my whatever
and then he goes and finds it yes that
he finds something and he can bring it
back except if it has any value people
are going to assume that the reason he
knows where it is and who to take it to
is he stole it from them and so he spent
his childhood early childhood learning
the hard way that returning things to
people
brands you as a thief and gets you
beaten up sometimes and so he's shy
about it but the story Lost and Found is
about the idea of how does it come to
have a practical use to maybe help
somebody save somebody's life and you
got to have something like that somehow
your protagonist has to be able to do
something heroic or you might as well be
James Joyce and have no on purpose you
know there there
there are many readers of James Joyce
most of them in graduate school because
you can't do that to undergraduates they
are not ready they haven't got the
discipline they haven't proved that
they're willing to put up that amount of
garbage and try to say smart things
about it and so if you want to have no
audience at all then by all means have a
character no one cares about because
nothing he does matters but in in the
case of science fiction and fantasy you
got to have the hero he doesn't always
have to be nice
there are several science fiction
writers who have made their career about
writing about not very nice people and
you know I mentioned George Martin and
Game of Thrones is there a nice person
in Game of Thrones maybe arguably one
one and a half but that's about it
everybody else does things that are just
you just think are you insane are you
evil and the answer often is both and so
but it but it's still very powerful
because it's very realistic that's the
change that science fiction and fantasy
of both main is you can't just throw
magic on the page and make it fantasy
you have to make it fantasy that would
pass muster with a science fiction
writer because that's who's writing
fantasy now is mostly science fiction
writers and they got their training in
the discipline of always having to
explain things so they make sense so
there's a logic so there are rules and
so a good fantasy will explain it's
magic system in such a way that the
stories can arise out of it because we
know that not just anything can happen I
taught the Judson Jerome once
poet who also wrote for writers digest
for many years and I given him my novel
seventh son which is the first of my all
that maker fantasy series and he handed
it back to me says I said writings fine
but when anything can happen it doesn't
matter what happens and that is a true
statement but what he didn't know as a
non fantasy reader was how carefully I
had set up the rules of what can and
can't happen so that by the time your
recorder the way into the book the rules
are there and they're set and I don't
violate them through
next five volumes after that and so he
didn't know how to read fantasy he's not
schooled in that and fantasy readers
quickly school themselves nobody gives a
class on how to read fantasy you just
read fantasies until you get it and if
the story is satisfy you great and if
they don't read something else so it's a
nice liberty of reading in just one
second I want to ask you about how
detailed you get in terms of your
outlining process in your prewriting
process before you even sit down to
write but first I want to give a moment
to give a shout out to all of our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible if they were not
advertising on the show the show would
not exist and if you were not
patronizing them they wouldn't exist so
we appreciate everybody working together
during this difficult time let's talk
about one of those advertisers right now
an advertiser who's doing a lot to keep
the country running I'm talking of
course about zip recruiters zip
recruiter their focus hasn't changed
they're still doing what they've always
done they're helping people find work
they're helping businesses find the
right people for their open roles if
you're looking for a job zip recruit is
working with you to find the right job
faster that has never been more
important they are dedicated to helping
you get hired from caretaking to
delivering food and goods building
medical facilities supplying protective
equipment and so much more and also
getting back into the workforce as we
begin reopening in fact zip recruiters
app will send you up-to-date job
openings so you can be one of the first
to apply and if you're actively hiring
zip recruit will invite candidates to
apply to your most urgent roles making
it faster and easier to reach the people
you need by connecting people who need
jobs and companies that need people
zip recruiter is working with all of us
so we can keep moving forward let's work
together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
again never been a more important time
in American history to connect
presumptive employees and presumptive
employers connecting the best people
with each other that's what zip
recruiter does check them out right now
at zip recruiter comm slash work
together so when it comes to your actual
writing process how much do you do
outlining and how much of it is you sort
of a rough idea of where you're going
and then you sort of let the characters
of the plot take you where you're going
so I know writers who are both schools
all of us and that's in fact there is
more than one school more than two
schools I mean but in fact I always do
some degree about I try to think ahead
mostly menu development what
the rules of magic how does the science
work in this if I need fast faster than
light travel what is my justification
for it because you know we have a grab
bag of stuff that all science fiction
writers use back in the 40s and 50s in
the candle era of science fiction the
writers were inventing all these things
but now we just shop from their shelves
and take what we need but that doesn't
involve a degree of outlining there when
I have a character and I have perhaps an
antagonist or an obstacle he needs to
overcome or a goal then I'll think of
obligatory scenes things that have to
happen and I have to then set up those
scenes so they mean something so the
reader will care and so there's some
planning that goes into it
I know writers who think like
screenwriters and they write up all the
story not not actually writing the prose
of the story but notecards with every
important scene the way screenwriters
often do and then they can shuffle these
note cards around and paste them in
different places on the wall and you
know in other words they their thought
is all on the board I can't do that
because anything that I wrote for
anything after chapter 2 is going to be
discarded as soon as I find out what's
going on in chapter 1 and I never know I
have a plan I know what's supposed to
happen in Chapter 1 but what if one of
my little bit characters that I use as a
little placeholder just to get some
exposition going turns out to be really
fun what if my knots character is more
interesting than my main character I
have been known to elevate nantes
characters into major figures sometimes
they'll replace somebody who is already
in the on line and do the same jobs they
needed to do but later sometimes they
just carve their own way in but the
process is pretty flexible because by
the time on nearing the end of any novel
the outline is now relic deserving to be
covered with dust it has almost nothing
to do with what I ended up writing so I
have to plan in order to get the
confidence to proceed but then I don't
people
and back at the outline now this is
frustrating to editors who believe that
they're supposed to receive the
manuscript that was promised in the
outline I gave them which is even more
sketchy and it's never happened yet
though they thought that that particular
strand I've seen an example an early
novel by Dean Koontz where it looked
obvious to me that after developing a
cast of amazing wonderful characters the
readers cared about he caught up with
the point in the outline where they all
go into an alien spaceship together and
at that point he was just following the
outline and it didn't matter who any of
the characters were it's the same thing
Stephen King did in the stand his set up
this great cast of characters and then
because of his good Calvinist upbringing
it felt right to him at the very end
that after all they did it amounted to
nothing and the finger of God comes out
of the sky and destroys the missile and
I just threw the book across the room I
was fearing it was a hardcover - so
that's an expensive heaven but it was
just outrageous to me because I am so
not a Calvinist and so you know we
Mormons aren't a Calvinistic and and so
we believe that the human activity
actually matters to God and therefore
he's not going to make it so that
everything we sacrificed was meaningless
anyway it was unsatisfying to me I think
it's unsatisfying to a lot of people
that it just ends with God doing what he
could have done in the first place and
spared them an awful lot of trouble but
that's you know each author has to write
from his own unconscious and from what
feels right and true to him and so I
learned very early on that while I
admire Stephen King and enjoyed many of
his works especially early ones I had no
desire to write anything that he would
write because I don't like horror and
I'm not sympathetic to it I don't read
it if I can avoid it and one of his best
books Pet Sematary as I was reading it I
realized how good heavens they keep
mentioning the busy road their little
boy is gonna get hit by some vehicle and
then dead he's going to be buried in the
pet cemetery so come back to life but
come back to life as a monster so I
skipped ahead to the end and realized
that yes I had nailed it that was
exactly what happened and by the way
anybody who thinks I'm committing
spoilers if you haven't read these
things by Stephen King by now it's your
own fault and so anyway it's not like
Stephen King has been a secret that I
was holding close to the vest but but I
decided to write my anti Pet Sematary
story where a child dies and haunts his
own family as a ghost but is still
himself is still a good person that he
was and that's my novel Lost Boys so it
didn't sell like that Cemetery I just
thought I'd mention that if sales that
should only measure that cemetery is a
much better book but then again Pet
Cemetery hit the shelves marked as
written by Stephen King and mine hit the
shelves as mark marked as written by
Orson Scott Card and without enderwiggin
in it so you know diminished its chances
greatly but still there are people who
tell me that it's my best book including
myself but you know it's one of those
things where you don't get to pick what
the public wants most and you're just
glad that they want anything let's talk
for a second about the messaging in your
book so you mentioned that it's
sometimes you'll read other books and
you'll feel like there's a message
that's being put out there that isn't
good by the way I had the exact same
reaction to the stand the first time I
read it I thought the first 400 page of
this are pretty breathtaking and by the
time we hit the end and everything just
explodes which has become sort of dreg
or firm for all of Kings novels it seems
like the last 10 or so novels basically
a bunch of stuff happens and then just
everything explodes at the end it's one
of my big fatigues okay but putting that
aside how do you yeah every so often I
go back to it to read another King novel
and maybe this time they won't explode
but I'm wrong every single time every
single time somebody everything explodes
at the end it's very it's very
disquieting actually but it when it
comes to deciding that the messages in
your novels do you sort of let the the
novel bring the message forward or do
you start with a message in mind and
then you say this is sort of what I want
to establish via the novel well I don't
think any of my novels have anything you
could call the
message there are people who think they
know what it is and they're always
ridiculously wrong I don't even know how
they got their idea from my book and I
think no they just brought this idea
with them and read what they wanted to
read but there are messages some
messages that are I'm aware of for
example in science fiction it's a
requirement really of writing acceptable
science fiction that you not have God be
an actor in in they play you can have
people believe in God you can actually
have God be an actor as long as you
explain God as a giant computer or etc
etc you in real science fiction you
won't find anything as ridiculous as the
force which just destroyed Star Wars for
me because it's so mystical and silly
and so well I really loved the first
movie in the second movie was pretty
good the more they get into the force
the less interested I am and then it's
like a sort of a pablum a milk-soaked
graham cracker of a religion and yet
there are people who for whom that has
become their religion so they're on baby
food and then that's good it's better to
be to satisfy your hunger with something
rather than nothing but I realized that
science tradition had character after
character that had no upbringing no
family background nothing they came out
of nothing it's just the hero is what
the hero does now that's romantic
storytelling capital R that's what you
find when you're reading the Middle
English romances characters come out of
nowhere the hero is Arthur you know
later they invented they backstory to
him with the stuff with Luther yeah
Lutheran Merlin and yet with her
Pendragon and Merlin all and stuff but
but no they were just concatenating
stories from different different
traditions in Brittany and then
spreading them out with the the
troubadours but by and large they have
no upbringing and so I start my
characters early people think that what
I do is I write novels about children
no I don't I read novels about humans
but humans begin as children and my
model was I want to write novels as if
they were biographies and if their
biographies I want to spend some time on
the thing that biographies do worst
which is deal with the childhood of the
figure that they're reporting on because
with rare exceptions like Winston
Churchill's letters home begging his
parents to come visit him or let him
leave his boarding school we don't have
anything from children's child from
famous people's childhood we get vague
vague intimations some remark that an
adult who knew him then said you know
what a precocious brat will that
distract half of them and and it's hard
to put together their childhood but when
I'm just making it up I have a
completely free hand it's the nice thing
that happened when James Cameron
arranged for me to write the
novelization of the abyss I asked him
for permission to do backstory on the
lead characters and he I said that's
what I do as a novelist so I need that
in order to know who they are so he gave
me the chance to write a couple of
chapters before the beginning of the
movie script and he gave them to the
actors to read I think they'd never read
them why would they all they had to do
was say the lines in the script and so
this was all waste of time stuff for
them but for me it was necessary in
order to turn it into a good novel Jim
told me that was the goal was he wanted
a good novel to be made from his movie
and there were a couple of places where
what I call a good novel surprised him
he was not always pleased along the way
but he eventually consented to what I
did and I'm not proud of the result I
think it is a good novel and and in some
ways better than the movie because he
didn't get to finish the movie the way
that he wanted to they ran out of budget
for some of the final special effects
and so what we end up with is it looks
like a fiberglass bathtub toy rising out
of the ocean instead of the shimmering
surface that it's supposed to have but
well there's no money you can't do the
special effects and so you know and and
some things were cut out of it
I thought were important but he still he
kept the things that were most important
to me he understood the story the same
way I did and that's good because it was
a great script that was back when Jim
Cameron still cared about the characters
and caring about the story and and so
the abyss ended up for me being true or
filmed then some of his later and bigger
blockbusters swear you know come on if
he cared about Titanic it would have had
believable dialogue Titanic is one of
those few movies that's better if you
turn the sound off because then when you
get to the sinking scene it's
magnificent he did such a glorious job
of making that real you just don't want
to have to hear the things people say it
just works better that way the opposite
movie is twister which which was treated
in Hollywood as if it were a crapfest
devised by an you know studio executive
we need a tornado movie but the writers
made it better than it needed to be they
made it wonderful with that one you can
turn off the visual and listen to the
audio and get a great movie because the
dialogue is so good and the ensemble
acting is so good so you know you can
make you know both movies succeeded but
but Titanic was a monster hit and who
knows maybe audiences don't care about
dialogue quality I want to ask you about
the development of Enders games he
mentioned that it started off the short
story had been in your head for a really
long time where did the idea for Ender's
Game come from and then how did you move
from a short story to a novel because
that's that's a pretty massive increase
in in size and scope want to get to that
in the answer that in just one second
first when you're at work you really
don't think about your IT department
that much but they are protecting your
online safety and security well now
you're not at work now you're working
from home if you're working at all and
this means you need to protect yourself
the best way to do this expressive VPN
it's the best online protection possible
I've been talking about expressvpn on my
show for a long time you should
understand why encrypting your network
data is so important let me remind you
hackers are out there looking for your
data plus there is PS that actually sell
your data to the highest bidder
you might be thinking security threats
don't affect you personally but not
using expressvpn that would be like
leaving your front door unlocked every
time you go out nothing might happen for
years but when a break-in does happen it
could be devastating one of the
easiest ways to secure your internet
data is with expressvpn you click one
button on your computer or your
smartphone and now you are magically
protected you're protected from being
hacked you're protected from having your
data sold my only question is why
haven't you gotten expressvpn yet visit
my special link right now at expressvpn
calm / ban that's e^x PR ESS VPN comm /
ban it next for three months of
expressive VPN for free
protect your internet today with the VPN
I trust to keep my data safe
that's expressive VPN calm / pen again
expressive VPN calm / man expr ESS VPN
calm / man okay so I was gonna ask you a
moment ago about the idea for Ender's
Game where that came from and then how
you went about moving it from a short
story form to a novel form which is a
pretty radical expansion the idea for
Ender's Game actually began on my 16th
birthday my older brother and his
soon-to-be fiance and now wife gave me
two books with the word Foundation on
the cover by Isaac Asimov one was
Foundation and the other one was second
foundation they logically assumed that
that was the first and second volume of
the trilogy but no it's the first and
third volume because of reasons that are
clear when you read them but I read
Foundation and was blown away it was the
best science fiction I'd ever read I've
been reading and read Norton and Robert
Heinlein's juveniles and this one took
me up another level as it did a lot of
science fiction readers when it first
came out in the magazines in the 50s and
after I was through reading that I
thought I want to be able to write
something like that I want to be able to
write science fiction I want to try
doing that and so I thought what idea
well my older brother was on leave from
the military and was about to be
stationed at Fort Dundas in Salt Lake
very close to our home in Orem and he
had come home from basic training and
from Officer Candidate School full of
stories about good things and bad things
about the way that people were trained
and so I thought how would you train
people for war in space and I remembered
a book by North Hoffman hall and I wish
I could remember the title but it's
about Americans who joined the lafayette
escapade France during World War one
and one of the things that really stood
out for me was that these new trainee
pilots were warned that the way that
most pilots died was that they didn't
know to look in three dimensions they
would only turn their heads like this
yeah and they wouldn't see because the
enemy that's gonna kill you was gonna
come out of the Sun he's gonna come from
above and behind you he's gonna come
from below you have to have a
three-dimensional sense and I thought
okay how do you train people to think
three dimensionally and I invented it in
my mind at the battle room an enclosed
space in which there's zero gravity and
you train to move against likewise
wargaming enemies I invented a flash
suit so that your hits are recorded
there can be no arguing and of course
the walls around it were there so you
didn't keep losing trainees as they
drift off into space you don't have to
have anybody going out shagging flying
humans and so the the game idea was a
great idea but I didn't know how to turn
it into a novel how is that a novel what
do you do with a novel that you know
with the training ground as the basis
for a novel so I sat on that one for
years I worked on it a bit inventing new
stuff thinking of new things about it
while I was on my mission in Brazil when
I came home I was still mentally working
on it now and then but then when I got
that letter from from Ben Bova telling
me that analog published his science
fiction and I was sending him fantasy as
there were trees in it and I thought
okay I know a sci-fi idea it's this
battle room and so I started writing it
with no real plan except that I had
decided that the soldiers who were being
trained were children because children
are still young enough that they can
really absorb the reorientation of
three-dimensional space in a way that
adults just can't too many bad habits
and so starting with children 9 10 11
pre-puberty I came up with a short story
Ender's Game but then when it was time
to write the novel what it is is that I
had sold to tor books who was a new
startup fantasy science fiction line at
that time there were no new startups
everybody knew that it would fail but it
was Tom Dougherty who was the publisher
so he knew how to make it work and one
of the things he did was he got a book
for me called that we were calling
speaker for the dead but it dawned on me
that speaker for the dead would work
only if enderwiggin from that short
story was the protagonist but then I had
to somehow explain how we got from one
of the others so I asked him I was at an
ABA in Dallas and I asked him Tom I need
to do a novel version of Ender's Game
first
and he said sure same terms as speaker
for the dead I said absolutely and on a
handshake we did it I went home and
here's the thing that I had already
learned from taking a short story called
Michael songbird and turning it into a
novel song master you don't have the
short story be the first chapter of your
book in fact you leave the books so that
the climax of the short story is the
climax of the book you just go back
earlier and you provide a better and
different and richer and deeper lead up
to that climax which is what enters game
is still leads to the same climax except
that after the climax there's a long
chapter in which we see what happens to
enter afterward and it's the reason why
he becomes the speaker for the dead and
it seems to work pretty well both novels
won Hugo's and nebulous so at least at
the time certain people approved of it
at least slightly more than one-fifth of
each voting group and they both still
work and and so that technique of taking
a short story and turning into a novel
by starting earlier it's now kind of my
hallmark I've done it with other
novellas novelettes and short stories
and it's the only way to go I've watched
the results when other people take their
prize-winning short story and have it be
chapter 1 and usually the stuff they
think about
has suffers from bad sequel itis the
story really ended where they ended it
in the first place their instincts were
right that was the ending so leave it as
the ending and that's what I tell myself
so but you know one of the things you
asked me earlier about my message one of
the most important ones for me was this
there was no religion in science fiction
the characters could you know God
couldn't be a character but I realized
there is no such thing as a human being
without a religion I've learned this
with many atheists over the years I've
learned it I learned it at Notre Dame
with with a good Catholic grad students
along with me who nevertheless didn't
act as if their religion mattered but I
found that if you keep questioning
things and start casting doubt on things
that they did not believe could be
doubted you find people's religion
because they get angry you find the
thing that they believe that they don't
realize might not be believed by by
other people by intelligent people and
so everybody has religion everybody has
the beliefs that they don't realize they
believe because that's just how things
are they think and as soon as you
question those things there's a little
panic a little a little sense of of
assault on their basic core nature so
once I understood that everybody has a
religion I decided why don't I have my
characters openly have religions they
don't have to be mine in fact they
usually aren't and even when they are
it's not necessarily the version of my
religion that I believe in you know if I
were Jewish and I were and let's say
conservative and I made somebody Hasidic
or I made somebody reformed then it
wouldn't necessarily be following my
belief set yet I would know something
about the culture at least what it is
that I do that makes them both yell at
me and so you know if you're gonna
create a character you need who has an
existing religion you have a
responsibility to make it plausible
so it's speaker for the dead I made it a
Catholics hundred colony
Brazilian but in Brazil you find that
only a certain not tiny but minority of
the population is believing practicing
Catholic a lot of people who are
nominally Catholic are following no I
can never remember the name right my
Kumba's what comes it comes to mind but
it's one where African gods have been
assigned the names of saints and it's
essentially the African religion in
disguise as Catholicism the priests are
aware of it there's nothing they can do
about it so they just let those people
come and take communion with the strict
Catholics but Brazil while it takes
pride in being the world's largest
Catholic country is not all that
Catholic except that this colony was
founded with the idea of Catholicism at
its core if you come to this colony to
live you care about Catholicism you're a
believer and a practicing so I had to
know enough about Catholicism to not
make idiotic mistakes now fortunately in
America we have two generic religions if
you need a hierarchical religion you use
Catholic if you need a congregation or
religion you use generic Protestant but
really Baptist and that is what works so
you can have stories for somebody's and
minister as soon as the same Minister
you know not Catholic have story were
seventies of priests soon as the robes
are on or whatever then you know you got
Catholic every now and then you know
with the bishops wife you have the the
Anglican idea and so so you know it
varies but those religions are available
and we all have some experience in them
by watching movies Jewish not so much I
would feel a great deal of trepidation
making a character of mine Jewish
especially Orthodox because I've known
enough worth adducts Jews to know how
rigorous the demands are what has to be
kept in your head all the time and I do
that as a Mormon you know I know all of
our rules by heart I don't even have to
think about them anymore
but whenever I watch some of these
fictional treatment of Mormonism I just
know one
ever gets it right no one even comes
close
a very famous rock musician his work I
enjoy wrote a novel that had Mormon and
he wanted me to read it to maybe get a
quote for the cover and I I started
reading at night within the first two
chapters I thought none of this could
possibly have him this is not the way
Mormonism ever ever ever works and so my
best response was just silence because
he couldn't revise the novel yet he now
it was too late
but getting somebody else's religion
wrong is a terrible faux pas but showing
characters who have a religion that they
take seriously is I think a really good
and useful thing to a degree and Tyler
has tried to do that Saint maybe and and
other books have people who are
believers in a religion the trouble is
when she wants us to take a religion
seriously she makes it more of mere
christianity than of any particular
denomination and that's fine I mean
that's CS Lewis's influenced too but it
also strips the religion of its demands
the religions that are prospering right
now in America are the high demand
religions Orthodox Jews are not
shrinking reform is the mainline
Christian churches Lutheranism
Presbyterianism they are what can I say
losing members shedding members but the
high demand Protestant religions the
ones that actually expect you to live my
rules
those are growing and so you know it's
just one of those things that when you
belong to religious culture that expects
you to behave in certain ways in order
to be a full-fledged member it changes
your life
if focus is your life and and so you
know I've toyed with using Mormonism but
then I know no matter what I do it's
gonna make Mormons mad and I need to be
able to go home from time to time and
visit family so so it's just easier for
me to use other people's religion the
one time I did use my own religion was
the novel loss about two times London ah
the Lost Boys and a story collection
call
folk at the fringe and in both of those
there are Mormons who'd just hate them
you know who's going to write about a
Mormon what could be right about a good
one Wow all the things you and your
stuff that I actually did it's me you
hate but anyway that's that's one of my
minor messages people have religion and
the fiction writer who retreats from
that is cheating himself in his readers
so let's talk for a second about your
your experiences in the industry because
obviously you are religious you are also
politically conservative you've written
before about how about a president you
think President Obama was I'm not sure
exactly where you stand on on President
Trump
per se but the the there obviously has
been a long time blacklist in Hollywood
for people who are conservative I'm well
aware of it I wrote an entire book about
the the blacklist in the TV industry the
my business partner Jeremy boring ran
Friends of Abe which was the underground
Hollywood Organization for conservatives
so how has your career been affected
obviously I know that you're at one
point I asked pretty you know pretty
publicly to do some comic books for DC
and then thanks to the outraged mob that
was canceled and you know that wasn't a
big deal that money was pathetic but it
was just fun and I was collaborating
with a very good writer and we were good
artist so you know that's fine black
lists only work when people are afraid
because the blacklist
you know I am blacklisted not just in
Hollywood but in fact there's constant
harping and sniping there's no
forgiveness ever even when you already
say look the issues moot I lost let's
move on they don't want to move on if
once they have a stick to beat you with
the beatings continue but in Hollywood
it makes no difference I was never gonna
make a career there anyway I'm already I
was already too old they want young
writers and I didn't like the idea that
I had other people who had the right to
give me notes and make me follow them
because hi only a couple of times got
good notes from smart people there are
smart people in Hollywood there are good
people in Hollywood they just don't have
the power to greenlight a film because
you get to that place in a Hollywood
bureaucracy by avoiding trouble by not
sticking your neck out and then you're
given authority and power because
they're running in terror they are all
afraid that they'll be like Mike Ovitz
and find out when they leave their job
their nobody they cease to exist and
that's the most frightening thing in the
world to them so nobody's gonna stick
their neck out for me and I don't care I
make so much more money from books than
anybody makes as a Hollywood
screenwriter that sounds awful but if
you're out to make a living
screenwriters can make money just by
getting hired for a job and then their
strip never gets used so you can write
your brains out for an entire career and
never have a movie produced or if it is
produced it bears no resemblance to the
script you wrote why would I want that
it's what I tell my writing students if
you want to have to write a movie do
what Ira Levin did with Rosemary's Baby
what Erich Segal did with with love
story I
they sent around their scripts nothing
happened nobody was interested so they
wrote them as short novels and they are
short novel screenplays make really a
novella
not a novel and they became monster
bestsellers and then when they went to
Hollywood and Hollywood will actually
when Hollywood came to them they said
there's this script if you shoot the
script then you have a chance at getting
the rights but if you don't shoot my
script you're not getting the rights and
I said that's how you sell a screenplay
is write the novel make it have it sell
a billion copies and then you are in the
catbird seat but most people can't do
that or don't do that and you're you
know only JK Rowling at living memory
has had the power as a novelist to
insist that she gets the final say on
casting and scripts and etc and even
then her power
but at least she had the sense to know
that to know that there were things she
just could not affect because they were
the requirements of film but so I'm not
troubled by what's happened in film dome
or television land to my work we did get
a TV series put on by BYU television but
then they had a management change in the
series was dropped even though it was
getting really good responses it's one
of those things where if it didn't grow
in their garden they're not interested
and so you know those things happen but
I once had a TV series that was going to
pilot and the guy who was the showrunner
to be basically he had made it a band
and this is what came back to me my
lawyer calls me and he says well Scott
here's the good news they're gonna take
your script to pilot so it has a chance
to go on air but you're fired
they don't want you to show up on set
and I just laughed yeah I was wasn't
heartbroken because I didn't count on
anything no matter how real it looks
it's not real until you see it on the
screen and so they really can't hurt me
by depriving me of a Hollywood career
that I don't actually want now if
somebody really wants to make something
and then fights for it and makes it
happen great but right now in this
climate
they don't censor you for what sin is in
the script they censor you for your life
and I was already running into
resistance before I ever made any
political statements just because I am a
member of the Church of Jesus Christ of
latter-day saints and say so serve the
mission for the Mormon Church it gave me
fluency in Portuguese which has been
useful but it is not a credential that
anybody is impressed with in the world
of literature either I run into people
who assume even within the Mormon Church
who assume that in order to become a
writer I must have lost my faith you
know so I've gotten letters like this
your book Saints gave me a picture of
Joseph Smith
believable so real it was so wonderful
it increased my own belief in him when
did you leave the church and I'm going
what I haven't left the church but they
assume that it's just taken for granted
in our culture that if you're an
intellectual and especially if you make
a living doing it electrical stuff you
can't possibly be a believer because if
you're an educated person you must have
left faith behind long ago but that's
not true I'm a very well educated person
and it all only brought me closer to my
faith my rational means as well as I
felt spirituality so a second I want to
ask you about the movement in sci-fi
away from I would say interesting things
and toward a very specific brand of
politics which is pretty obvious to
anybody who follows the sci-fi genre
particularly if you look at the the
books that they actually end up with
reviews in the New York Times and The
Wall Street Journal you get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
how unpredictable life is okay life is
unpredictable bad things happen like
four months ago Bernie Sanders was the
presumptive nominee and the unemployment
rate in America was 3.5%
because life is unpredictable this is
why you need insurance it's why
insurance exists policy genius is the
insurance marketplace you need there's a
huge demand for life insurance right now
if you're looking to get life insurance
here's how they can help policy genius
will compare quotes from the top life
insurance companies all in one place it
takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from the top insurers and find
your best price that doesn't just save a
lot of legwork you could say 1500 bucks
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork and the red tape for
free they're in contact with life
insurance companies every step of the
way
monitoring developments helping
customers navigate every step cross life
insurance off your to-do list right now
if you're one of the many people looking
to buy life insurance right now but
you're not sure where to start policy
genius calm is the place policy genius
will find you the best rate handle the
process completely get your life
insurance auto insurance disability
insurance get all the insurance you need
to protect against the vicissitudes of
life policy genius calm so let's talk
for a second about what what feels
increasingly like the decline of the
sci-fi genre as it is taken over by
social justice warriors so I'm a big fan
of sci-fi I've been reading sci-fi
literally all my life the good news is
novel comes out I'm the first to get it
I'm I would say fairly well read in the
genre at this point having read maybe a
thousand different books alright but it
seems like everything that gets reviewed
now is something that is rooted
fundamentally not in interesting plots
or interesting premises or interesting
worlds but in a brand of politics that
is radical and so if you write a
character who is transgender that is
much more important than actually
writing a story that is worth reading or
if you write an entire book that is
rooted in a specific type of gender
politics in which men are evil and women
are good then that is likely to receive
a rave review from the New York Times
even if it doesn't actually have
anything particularly interesting to say
well what do you make of the attempt to
take over the the sci-fi genre fantasy
genre to buy the political left is
pretty obvious that that's happening
yeah it is
science fiction is more vulnerable to it
because science fiction is in some sense
is culturally irrelevant now you can
find so many mainstream books that use
sci-fi themes almost every thriller is
actually science fiction you don't have
to write in science fiction to write
science fiction you can write all kinds
of things now Kurt Vonnegut did a kind
of semi arty writing along with plenty
of sci-fi in all of his work while
denying he was a science fiction writer
and refusing to have it labeled with a
genre on the covers of the books and
that was fine he paved the way for a lot
of people but right now if you want to
write science fiction you can just write
a mainstream thriller or a spinal or
pretty much anything you want to write
and a lot of the people you know David
Foster Wallace definitely was writing a
lot of stuff that had to be classed this
sci-fi er would have been in 9 to 1950s
so and then look at Margaret Atwood who
simply is bad bad bad at science fiction
but she uses science fiction motifs in
all the ignorance of her arrogance I
mean I've met her personally therefore
my detestation is far beyond what I
would do for literary reasons but she
writes bad science fiction but it gets
taken seriously by the literary
mainstream because it's not published as
science fiction so
in a way you know I watched this begin I
watched it with people that I liked who
were simply writing the conscience but
their conscience was ill informed and
when I complained about it in reviews I
was pounced on unbelievably so usually
reviewers get a pass they're just
writing their opinion but I was savaged
for writing a review that was negative
about a hate all men all men are evil
all men want women to scream with pain
when they have sex with them story from
I think in the 80s might have been the
90s and so I was prepared for the fact
that that was taking over I walked out
of the science fiction writers of
America without a scene usually you're
supposed to write a flaming letter to
one of the science fiction writers of
America publications that's the
tradition all I did was stop paying my
dues and you know that works really well
and it doesn't make a scene but I
haven't been a member of that community
for a long time because when you look in
science fiction in the bookstore the few
bookstores we have left you'll find that
most of the books in the science fiction
fantasy area are fantasy and fantasy is
not getting taken over because that's
where the science fiction writers who
were fed up went and that's where George
Martin who may very well be holed social
justice warrior beliefs I have no idea
we've never had a discussion about that
but you won't find them in his very
realistic socially and even historically
even though it's a made-up history in
his game of Thrones books because he's
writing about people who were not
politically correct they didn't have any
idea like that he's writing about
barbarians and so he writes them as
barbarians and he does it honestly and
nobody complains about it and so and
even you know JK Rowling now she
pretends the Dumbledore is gay but
that's crap that came after the fact
there is not a single hint anywhere in
the books that she had any such idea
it's just after the fact trying to
explain herself to our T friends and she
should realize that her career would
have been impossible as she'd been
listening to them be
or she just wrote a story and Dumbledore
is just a guy and his sexuality does not
matter in the books she proved that by
the way she wrote it she wrote it wrote
him well and the aftermath stuff is just
garbage we just don't need it but that's
what happens is people try to justify
themselves so they won't be called
this or that ugly name but we're coming
to a point where those ugly names are
losing power radically when every white
person in America knows that they're
labeled as racist then that means
why keep trying because no matter what
you do you're gonna be labeled with
white privilege and racism and so you
know we raised our kids east of the
Mississippi precisely so explicitly we
talked about it we had lived in Utah
we'd lived in parts of California and we
wanted our kids to grow up in a place
where they would actually meet black
people at school and then we found out
that South Bend Indiana was not that
place because the segregation was almost
total just by neighborhoods but when we
moved to Greensboro our first visit
there when I was applying for a job at
the time we went to a near downtown
restaurant and two waiters approached us
one white one black the white guy says
hi I'm your white waiter for the evening
and this is that his name your black
waiter for the evening then they both
broke up laughing because they knew it
was ridiculous and they were both
serving when was the back server one was
the the waiter and but they just thought
it was hilarious and we realized you go
into McDonald's in Greensboro North
Carolina and black and white people come
in together sit down together eat lunch
together they're on the job together and
even though Greensboro is famous as a
town where segregation was challenged at
the world where it's lunch counter
nevertheless in the south black people
and white people talk to each other
sometimes they're yelling but they can
get along they know each other they live
cheek-by-jowl and so while they're still
race prejudice here let's let's not
pretend that there's not we find that in
Greensboro our kids grew up
having black friends and white friends
and that was all we could ask for was
that they got that multi racial view but
now black kids are being taught that all
white people are privileged which is
just not true and that all white people
hate them which is also not true but I
know now that all my people are getting
more and more nervous that no matter
what they say it's going to be turned on
them and used to call them the ugly name
racist and that is pretty much the
ugliest name that we have in our
vocabulary right now if you're looking
for your Tourette's list of words that
you should not speak words that will
wound the F word is now way way low on
the list
compared to because we hear it all the
time compared to racist wow that's
that's Savage and so you know we live in
in troubles times but I I'm not a
conservative and I'm really not I am
from 1976 a daniel patrick moynihan
liberal and I have not had to change any
of my fundamental ideas since then but
somehow believing the same stuff has
turned me into a conservative so when I
was writing my column for awhile I would
get letters from people saying why don't
you become a Republican why are you
still registered as a Democrat and I
said Republicans don't want me either
with the things I believe if I became a
Republican and somehow came to
prominence then I would just find out on
on Fox that
what's his Hannity would label me as a
rhino or a publican and name only
because I believe in very liberal
immigration laws and I believe in gun
control and all kinds of other and I
don't like the death penalty at all as
long as it's administered by humans it's
going to end up executing innocent
people and so I have my beliefs that
just don't square with the right now
right wing mantras the the shibboleths
of conservatism now most of those are
not things that I would have thought of
as conservative
in the 1960s the Conservative Party has
moved to some weird radical position
that includes issues that I think are
just why should this be barrier to
becoming a Republican why should you
have to believe these mutually exclusive
things but both parties have those and
both parties are very mean to their
people who look toward the middle of the
road you know every time someone says
something bad about Mitt Romney I think
you had a Republican who ran as a
Republican won in Massachusetts and
governed successfully how did he do that
by getting along with Democrats in
Massachusetts that's the only way you
can do it so why are they surprised that
he has moderate policies and positions
why do they treat that as if you know
were some horrible birth defect that
disqualified him for high office because
well Mitt Romney was never my candidate
mostly because he adopted the you know
be mean to immigrants thing which is not
my feeling at all nevertheless he was a
better candidate than the man who became
president or was re-elected as president
and so you know I I just don't
understand the Republican Party the big
tent position is available to them and
they aren't taking it there's they're
narrowing and restricting which just
guarantees an eventual Democratic
victory if not in 2020 then the next
time around because even though the
Democrats are even more rigidly at
savagely against anybody who takes the
moderate line for some reason they are
the default party of an awful lot of
people in America and the Republicans
aren't and so if they're both being
restrictive Democrats win but the
Republicans could could become the big
tent party they nominated Trump instead
and that's that's where I am I'm afraid
that in 2016
I felt that both parties had nominated
the worst candidate they had ever
nominated in the history of the party
but it turned out that I could live with
Trump that
than I could live with an obvious
criminal and liar and etc and so I voted
for Trump you know I had a friend who's
had a hashtag on Twitter that hold nose
vote Trump and that's the category I was
saying I was certainly not a never Trump
ER and I have admired the fact that even
though I hate a lot of the promises he
made he's actually kept them more than
any other politician I've ever seen in
American history
Trump has kept promises and you have to
give a guy credit for that because
Democrats elect candidates who make
promises that the Democrats are counting
on them not to keep Clinton ran as a
moderate but his his voters his party
assumed that he wouldn't keep those
promises and that he voted governed from
the left in which he did for the first
few years until Newt Gingrich gave him a
lovely wake-up call with his contract
with America and Obama of course the
left most senator the US Senate was
elected but hope and change sounded open
and all-embracing
instead of rigid left-wing policies
which is where he went and so you know
as long as the Democrats are willing to
pretend to be middle-of-the-road and
Republicans are not willing to nominate
a candidate who actually is
middle-of-the-road we're in trouble
I want to ask you about your just book
recommendations in movie and TV so
obviously you're incredibly well versed
in all of this stuff where your favorite
sci-fi authors and what are some of your
favorite sci-fi movies and TV series
well here's here's the problem i I'm an
old man but I never had a memory for
lists I can't go through a list like I
could walk through my bookshelves and
point them out and say this one this one
this one but I also don't read science
fiction now III know science fiction too
well I'm the 70s and 80s
I reviewed every short story published
and I burned out so now I'm three pages
into a science fiction novel ago he's
doing one of these he's doing that such
a mistake how's he gonna compensate for
it no so you know III just know too much
but I don't understand how mysteries
work yet I mean I do on a superficial
level but I can read good mystery
so you know a new Michael Connelly comes
out or or a new Robert craze or or there
are some new writers whose names I will
not be able to bring to mind that I'm
really enjoying new green man novel
comes out and it's fine you know not the
greatest writing in the world I'm
reading one right now that has the
horrible mistake a first-person
present-tense
whenever he's following the main
character the gray man I just think why
why does he have to adopt that asinine
thing from creative writing programs in
American universities but that's you
know he's free to do whatever he wants
and it's working pretty well because
most of its in third person past tense
like a real American novelist and so
there are you know there are wonderful
writers in mystery soo draft instead I'm
deeply disappointed I'm also thrilled
that she's not allowing any into it to
continue her series now that was a good
will she wrote and and I also read a few
mainstream things but I also read
nonfiction right now I'm listening on an
audible to one of the great book series
that fortunately the not great books
great courses that the great courses
people have made available on audible so
I'm listening to one that's pretty
current with the science on great
moments or great turning points in
evolution which is really well done and
has actually taught me stuff that didn't
with my constant reading in the field I
still didn't know about and so you know
good job then but I'm also reading a
book on walking and that one's on Kindle
so I'm not listening to it and etc etc
I'm constantly listening to an audiobook
this earphone that I have in my ear for
this discussion is my normal position in
life because I have my little audible
player on a lanyard around my neck it's
also a full smartphone it's the unit
Hertz
atom telephone which is my audio book
reader my audible reader and I always
have this left ear with an earphone in
it so grocery shopping driving whatever
I've got a book going so I read so much
more now because
that it's a little more expensive but
it's fine you know they they offer a
decent price so you know you asked to
recommend movies I'm I just before
coming up here I was flipping around
channels and do what I always do if
there's one of the great movies that I
love I stopped on it and start recording
it middle is whatever and watch it to
the end so I'm in the middle of die hard
right now
1988 I believe and that's still a great
movie so many imitations including its
own pathetic sequels but the original is
fine just like Rocky
the original Rocky is a wonderful
independent film the formulaic sequels
came later and that's fine if people
enjoyed them I'm happy I'm glad that
they made a lot of money you know I felt
like a chart off one of the producers of
that was a friend of mine and in the
later years of his life when he worked
with me on Enders came back before a
studio took over and you know I think he
could be proud of his work on rocky the
sequels I've never watched one of them
so I have no opinion except that I never
watched which is a choice but greatest
movies my greatest my list of greatest
movies you got mail shop around the
corner the original date you can watch
them both back-to-back and they're still
wonderful Love Actually he's just not
that into you
what is it something love oh it's uh uh
it's I think the thing is called about
time we had yeah whatever his name is
dun dun na and so you know again if I if
I had a list of movies up I have one on
my website at hat rack calm but it's way
out of date there have been some good
movies since then darkest hour was the
best film treatment of Churchill I've
ever seen usually they just have
somebody do a voice imitation and say a
couple of lines from the famous speeches
but we have to know that Churchill was a
pompous ass and a brilliant process
that he had lots and lots of powerful
ideas and he made them happen and some
of them were good which meant that his
proportion of good ideas compared to
other people in any of the other
governments during the war was
ridiculously high but of course he had
all the failures and failures that
weren't his faders that were blamed on
him but in darkest hour they did a
brilliant job of making him seem like a
real person it helps that they cast one
of our finest living actors in the part
and you know he it's just he's an actor
who can never do a part badly even if
it's in a dumb movie he's good
what was it called the one where they
were extracting them from the beach at
Dunkirk was it called Dunkirk
yeah I can't remember anyway it was it
was so bad I just hated it because what
they did was they took any anecdote that
fit the description the prescription of
film teachers film right screenwriting
teachers what they were told makes a
good movie and they put all those
together with just a handful of
characters and made to my mind and
incredibly boring and offensively unreal
treatment of Dunkirk it was as bad as
Saving Private Ryan
now William Goldman gave a brilliant
critique of Saving Private Ryan and
explained why even by the rules of of
screenwriting it was crap but it was
sentimental twaddle and well-made there
were great scenes in it they cast Tom
Hanks which is like casting Tom Cruise
it's something that is never a mistake
and you know people complain about Tom
Cruise because he's small and he keeps
getting cast as big men but I'm sorry on
the screen Tom Cruise is always ten feet
tall and that's just a fact about the
actor he has is owed so many Oscars that
went to other people
because they had the quote lead role on
quote I think of Rain Man
you know Dustin Hoffman found one thing
to do and just kept doing it with every
line but the movie depended on Tom
Cruise
being a sympathetic character who stood
in place of the audience and learned
what he needed to learn he was the
character who transformed he was the
character who changed and actors in the
Academy are just you know mostly yet
their voters are actors and they never
understand what good acting is they
always give sentimental responses and so
it went to Dustin Hoffman instead of
going to Tom Cruise who carried that
movie on his shoulders and so that kind
of thing happens as you can see I'm kind
of an opinionated guy these are the
kinds of opinions that would get me in
trouble if I mattered in Hollywood but I
don't and so I have the freedom to say
whatever I like but you know there are
TV shows that my wife and I watched
together some recent ones we were
enjoying the rookie I think it's the
best work of what's-his-name the actor
who Nathan Fillion let's see I'm so bad
with names and so you know we love that
it's got terrific writing and I'm just
catching up now on the series of Chicago
PD Chicago whatever drove a fire and so
on because I didn't realize they were
done by the same people who produced a
law-and-order and so I'm getting the
same fix I used to get from them good
writing good acting powerful stories and
the episode is always about the episode
not about the soap opera between the
characters that stuff goes on and it
helps add to the interest but it never
takes over that's what killed
moonlighting years ago when it was the
best thing on TV and by their third
season it was not good even the the
writers had lost their way completely
and you often been tuned in and there
was no story to carry you except the
soap opera and I didn't care about the
soap opera part so you know writers can
kill their own series lost was killed by
its writers but that's okay they lost
was begun by writers who had no idea
except an executive it said airplane
gets stranded on this island where weird
things happen and that was it you know
and so they had weird things happen and
it worked and maybe even specified some
of them but they were never able to make
it all come together and they ended with
not even a whimper
they ended with a wine and and and yet
at least it ended and so you know we we
had our era of about three years for a
loss was all he could talk about and
then no one had anything to say about it
because they stopped caring so when you
look for movies and you look for
television almost always the thing that
makes something have lasting value is
the writing and everybody in Hollywood
knows this they know that if you don't
have a script you've got nothing no
amount of directing can compensate for a
bad script they know it they say it
constantly but they still treat writers
like little bags of dirt that and and
that's you know they they'll try to put
a seed in about five at once hope some
of them grow and as soon as they can get
the fruit off the thing that grew then
they just kick that bag of dirt out of
the way because somehow directors got
supreme power it's not that way on
Broadway it's not that way in theater
the writer is everything the director
serves at his pleasure but you know in
Hollywood writers are treated like
nothing and the result is writers lives
there are filled with the agony and
frustration of watching bad movies get
made from their best work uh and so
there's so many bad movies people people
say why are there so many bad movies and
the answer is because decisions about
which movie to make are made by people
who have no idea what a good movie is
they have no idea what a movie will be
from reading the script plus they don't
even read the script they hire some
flunky to do it and then the flunky
tells them about it or writes coverage
on it and they make their decisions
based on that plus the filmography of
the people attached and they figure if
you got the same guy who is involved
with the Exorcist then it's got to be a
great hit even though it's not horror
doesn't have anything to do with
anything that made the addresses to hit
nevertheless they think that that magic
will then work and it doesn't it never
does so we're in a world where no one
knows what's good
no one knows what will work when it's
published but everybody thinks they know
including me but I'm no better at
picking winners than anybody else and
there'll be movies that I absolutely
adore mrs. what's-her-name lives for a
day
Peggy groom miss miss miss pettigrew
mrs. Pettigrew who lives for a day I
adored that movie I couldn't understand
why it was dumped in January the most
horrible slot for a movie to be released
and it was completely ignored at Oscar
time the performances were absolutely
brilliant
the writing was sharp and wonderful that
ironic and and sweet and yet disappeared
so I can't call it I have no idea and
then there are movies that I think well
this like I could smell this movie on
the way into the theater I didn't
realize the stink was coming from this
particular theater in the in the complex
but yeah this is the one that gave the
odor to the whole place and it goes
ahead wins an Oscar so what can I do I'm
my opinion on things I find it
fascinating but I can't think that
anybody else would so in just a moment
Scott and I are gonna be talking about
Western imperialism western cruelty
there are some folks on the Left critics
who suggest that Ender's Game is rife
with these sort of thematic so I'm gonna
ask Scott about that coming up if you
want to hear his answers head on over to
Daley wire.com and hit that subscribe
button become a member so be sure to
check out Orson Scott Card's work all of
it it really is great Ender's Game of
course is a classic you should go check
it out Scott thanks so much for stopping
by my pleasure
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike joiner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer case Winterton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex's
singhara editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]
you